Ahhh it's day 2, and I feel like shit
*Ding noise*
Amy's a little spy-like today
Mark: Mmmm that's good, that's nice
Amy: Spy pose
Amy: You can't see me
Mark: Where'd you go!?
[Laughing] Amy?! Oh there!
Okay, so we're gonna head over to the theater now.
Time to start the day. ~I still feel like shit~
~duh duh buh duh~ Bye room
Mark: Oh hello!
Dan: Oh good morning!
Mark: Hello. Good morning
Dan: Hi.
Do you not see this door with the giant star on it that says MY NAME!?..
Mark: ...Woo~ooh
Tyler (in background) : Thats a conference room.
Mark: That is, *offended scoff* aoh-obviously
...Star dressing room!
It does- I'm not even joking. It says STAR DRESSING ROOM!
It's HUUGE
Amy: What are you looking at?
Mark: I'm so coooooll~!
Mark: Look at this. See? Alright this is..
Amy: This is all [unintelligible]
Dan: Wow. You have two lamps.
Dan:  Look at those lamps you have.
Mark: I have 2 Lamps!
woh-ho-ho-ho
They're the-I'm gonna call them "The Lamps"
~Show entrance for "The Lamps™"~
WHO'S THAT MAN? ...who is you?? Who are you sir?
~Show entrance for ?????™~
Dan: *laughs*
Mark: You think you can compete with my incredible vlogging skills?
Dan: I don't think so.
Mark: I've already got a day of vlogging under my belt, and I am a champion.
Mark: Look at me.. Can you do this? Can you do this?
Dan: and you're modest about it too. Modesty.
Mark: Can you do this?!
Dan: ...Modesty
M: You can't, you can't do that.
Look at that face. Yeah. That's real nice
Anyway we're gonna go on stage. Right guys?
Wade: Oh yeah.
Bob: Do I have to?
Mark: *yells* Alright that was all I wanted.
Chase: *testing a microphone in background*
So this is the stage. Chase is the one that's shouting into the void over there. We're gonna do our warmups
It's gonna make a lot of sense, and then you're gonna see how we do the magic *jazz hands*
Bob: I want to talk about my penis.
Wade: Hey Mark-
Bob: I'M NOT DONE! MY PENIS is SO GOOD!! YOU HAVE NO IDEA!
Look at me. Look a' me. Look at me! Look Ah' ME!
Look at this!
Bob: BOO
Ethan: BOO
Tyler: BOO
Mark: BOO
Wade: BOO
Group: *Singing Fiive things. Five things, five things, five things. Fiiive things
Ethan: Five things that you would yell "AMY!!" at
Mark: Uhh. *stutter* i- uhh CHICA'S MISSING!!
Group: One!
Mark: THE INTERNET'S OUT!!
Group: Two!
Mark: WHAT HAPPENED TO MY BALLS!??
Group: Three!
Mark: THERE'S NOTHING IN MY CLOSET!
Group: Four!
Mark: I DON'T KNOW WHERE I AM!
Group: Five!
Group: *Singing* Fiive things. Five things, five things, five things. Fiiive things
Mark: Five things you accidentally put on that weren't your pants
Wade: *stutter* Amy! *starts laughing*
Group: *Laughs* (holy shit Wade)
Mark: Five things that you would do to cover up your baldness
Wade: Sex.
Group: (with laughter) One!
Wade: Uhh- Wear a mask.
Group: (with laughter) Two!
Wade: Uhh-Wear hair?
Group: (with laughter) Three!
Wade: Shave!
Group: (with laughter) Four!
Wade: Uhhh- Move really fast!
Group: (Laughing so hard they can barely speak) Five!
Group: *Singing and dying of laughter* Fiive things. Five things, five things, five things. Fiiive things
Group: *lots of laughter*
Mark: *while still laughing* I just imagine you're meeting new people and just WA-HAY
Group: *more laughter*
Group: *normal singing* Fiiive things
Ethan: Five things you would do with lock of my hair.
Mark: Braid it.
Group: One!
Mark: Frame it
Group: Two!
Mark: Bury It
Group: Three!
Mark: Create a voodoo doll
Group: Four!
Mark: UHHHH-Shove it inside of you
Group: (with laughter) Five!
Group: *Singing* Fiive things
Dan: Five titles for your Harlequin rooms romance novel that you're working on.
Tyler: My dick found the hole
Group: One!
*Laughter*
Tyler: Painted white with cum
Group: (with laughter) Two!
Tyler: Yellow is NOT her favorite color
Group: (with lots of laughter) Three!
Tyler: Everybody...hates..hemorrhoids
Group: (with lots of laughter) Four!
Group: *laughter*
Tyler: Ball-tastic jiggle lumpugus
Group: (Dying of laughter) Five!
Group: (broken up by laughter) *weakly singing* Fiive things. Five things, five things, five things. Fiiive things
Dan: That wins. That wins.
Wade: "Painted White With Cum"
Bob: (over the mic) Those- The harlequin ones are the kind where its like
*dramaticly* "She moved her hand down his milky trest and gripped the shaft." or like- stuff like that.
but they don't say like "he shoved his hueg dikk 'nside her!".
Group: *laughter amplified because of microphones*
Bob: And she was like "This is not my favorite color"
Mark: Hey, how's it going? Master pianist Markiplier here. I'm gonna play ya a ditty.
Kathryn, please insert music right here.
*epic music that Kathryn inserted*
*music comes to an abrupt stop suddenly*
Mark: *Moans multiple times over*
I'm feelin the music!
Dan(??): Working out some frustrations there?
Mark: *moans loudly*
Ethan: Welcome to my lair. This is my lair. Just right here
*Hits chair a few times*
Right in this cone here.
*Bob and Wade talking in background*
Ethan: Welcome, welcome.
Hey hey hey eyes are up here.
Alright. Let me tell ya-
*loud static noise*
Ethan: Was that you?
Mark: You be careful.
Wade: *Rapping* Yeah That's what I said "boom boom" ha now you dead. oh
Bob: That was..That was good actually yeah.
Mark: Wade. W-Wade!
Wade: Wha?
Mark: Wade, get back-come here
Ethan: Wade!
Bob: ah-AMY!!
Mark: Okay! I just did the warmup and sound check for my VIP audio thing. Uhhhhhhhhhh...
..Yeah. uhh  I'm gonna go get dinner now.
You're not gonna come along for that.
I'm sorry, it's just the way things are.
Go um...well, I mean you don't gotta go do anything because i'm gonna cut to the-
Anyway, so I'll be back *exhales in thought*
It's two hours till showtime. I'm sorry.
Wade: *Singing in a Gollum (from Lord of the Rings) voice*
AND IIII-IIIII HWHILL OLE'WAIZS LOVE YHUUUUU! precious
YJOUUUUUU
(Bob's voice at the background)
I will always...love youuuu
Mark: God, that was the worst thing I've ever seen in my entire life. I'm sorry I recorded that.
HEYY PHIL!
Phil:...what was that...?
Mark: Anyway so, um. It's been a fun day. I haven't seen any of Belgium at all.
We're in Belgium by the way. Antwerp.
Um, And it's pretty cool.
There it is, I guess.
uhhh
*weird voice* There's some mysteryyyy-ah shit it's a mannequin.
Alright anyway. I'm gonna let you guys go. Um-We're gonna go do the show, so I'll see you after the show is gone.
Okay cool! Bye! *kisses*
Evan: Alright guys, I just hijacked the camera.
Backstage here, let's go see what they're up to
Mark: *singing* Hey there baby, take off your clothes. I'm gonna make you touch your toes!
Turn around now, get on the bed,  We're gonna make things go to my head
and here we are!
*Ethan cleverly claps and cuts the scene*
Crowd: *laughter*
Mark: We are in intermission right now, which just is a European thing, that the Europeans make us do.
Ordinarily we don't have a European in-intermission in our European show, but the Europeans are really..
..sticklers about their European....traditions.
Evan: Shoutout Kathryn. Happy Birthday Kathryn
Mark: Happy Birthday Kathryn.
Everybody say "Happy Birthday Kathryn" in the comments below
...or else...
Alright look, I'm not gonna lie to ya.
We're all gonna die out there.
Maybe
Or not
No, maybe... I should- I take that back
We're all gonna be fine. We're gonna do a great show.
Look, I love you.
*pops lips* Anyway.
That's it.
*people talking in background*
*camera zooms in Evan's face*
Mark: *voice desynced* Hey guys, thanks for watching this awesome vlog of mine.
If you wanna see more cool stuff, go look up some cute kittens on the internet, because it would be better than what you saw here.
*chuckle*  Okay
Subscribe for more..
Alright, bye.
*voices in background while Evan hijacked the camera again*